good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy hump day
jackie have you humped anyone you love
this morning no i haven't though i did
get to sleep in a little bit with brutal
and that was really special and i felt
like that was a great way to ring in the
day
yeah but dude's not here and usually
he's our hump day mascot so it does feel
a little bit lackluster i'm definitely
like off today in a weird like
biological clockwise well we started a
little later today which is why if
you're watching on youtube the sun is
pouring in
so who knows what's kind of gorgeous i
mean it's really not you just have a
blind behind you and i don't so it's not
great for me but hopefully the sun does
what it does and it will continue to
rise and set
such a good call at some point in this
episode it will move on from this window
that's really brilliantly sad you know
like the sun waits for nobody so we had
pushed back today's episode i figured i
would need some major rest after night
two of luke combs of course i woke up
the same time i always do and i had all
this free time so i read a bunch of
errands that i needed to do because i
literally leave for tour tomorrow and
then i had breakfast with my sister
which was so nice you know
having breakfast like outside of your
home like going out to breakfast is a
really nice little treat you know yeah
it is it's so rare
it really is or how are you feeling
about the end log tour are you excited i
am i mean i don't know what i was
thinking doing back-to-back luke homes
concerts and then my tour because
what else would you have done not go to
the show
i probably wouldn't have
banged my neck back and forth so many
times i have to go get a massage after
this i cannot turn my neck like it is
fully stiff from two nights ago that's
an unforeseen cost and damage of the
luke combs concert if i was feeling
litigious
i might draw up a suit because i
literally cannot move my neck no and
like when that song comes on right like
even if
you swear to yourself i'm not gonna be
i'm not gonna snap my neck i'm not gonna
snap my neck you cannot you will find
yourself snapping your neck the sounds
just overcome yeah and you will snap
your knife so last night was great i'm
not gonna lie like i ca i can't choose a
favorite night he really changed up the
set list a lot which was nice because
most people only go to one show so if
you played the same set list like no one
would care um but we really got just
like two totally different experiences
the first night we went we had like
amazing seats we were so close to like
really in the thick of it and then last
night we were up in a suite which was
just so luxurious
um
i really got to just enjoy the show from
afar like i was watching the crowd a lot
like seeing these people in new york
sing a song about like
a large mouth fast no like you know i
was thinking a lot he sings his song my
kind of folk okay he says my people buy
beer on friday get rowdy on saturday
night they're all good people come
sunday under steeple and monday they'll
be right on time there ought to be a law
against working this hard and still
having that much fun i've never seen
people in new york sing a song about
working hard like ever in my life that's
just not one of our core values like you
know what i mean it was just shocking
like it was it was surprising yeah and
and going to church on sunday yeah like
it was just not something you hear and
people were just living for it it was so
good it was really
an honor a pleasure and a privilege to
be in the audience not once but twice
really so stunning was another great
night for me watching from my my bed you
guys having a great time counselor took
care she had really good footage yeah
counts really she does a nice job on
those ig stories so it was great to
watch you guys have so much fun and
yesterday was actually such a busy day i
can't believe today is december that's
you would never know it by this sunshine
behind me you know what it's december
[Music]
it's december you like that yeah and
yesterday we actually recorded a lot of
exciting tings so you actually shared a
vlog on the patreon yesterday how you
pack for the end log tour all your tips
and tricks and all the things that like
get you through being homesick and sad
and like making you feel comforted and
there was an exclusive peek at my
outfits i i'm changing it up i mean it's
still like similar but changing it up
and you're also changing it up from show
to show yeah i'm no longer wearing the
same thing every time and i'm no longer
wearing like disposable pajamas from
amazon like i spent a lot of money i
invested in good very cool
outfits that i think everyone will
really like i'm i'm not sure which one i
should wear i think i know which one i'm
going to wear but like tomorrow's a big
night opening night
and i think i know which one i'm going
to wear very cool and then last night i
recorded a podcast episode with zach
that will be up on friday because we
don't have an episode on friday because
as we said you will be and login so that
would be end log like oh my god i love
it okay but i also love the dj djt was
such like a
cultural moment yeah no but n log is
works for me can you do me a favor can
you just move your feet in frame so we
can get some new viewers free feet picks
over here okay i slid my shoes off
because my feet are getting hot in there
and i'm pregnant so i can do stuff like
that you know you know i want you to put
them in frame
no my feet are really not they're really
cute you have a pedicure i do have a
pedicure okay they're not bad and with
the sunlight on them it's kind of
gorgeous
all right if you like free feet picks
head over and subscribe to our channel
thanks
speaking of feet um on vanderpump rules
which i watched last night which was a
travesty per usual like on the next
week's episode they start selling feet
pictures to pay for our kel's nose job
that's a real storyline yeah and we're
supposed to just suspend disbelief that
we know these people a lot of them make
twenty thousand dollars an episode yeah
yeah you're kidding me yeah oh i think
that's where i actually draw the line
for real no last night's episode i would
say i ca i caught about fifteen percent
of it imagine being on my phone yeah no
of course and just like living your life
right so i will share my thoughts as
always but we've got a lot to talk about
today oh i hope everyone enjoyed porsche
williams the feedback was great yeah and
i really hope you guys get her book
she's really um
not like other girls no no no
and that was a really exciting like
pinnacle moment for us yeah oh also
today's a big day it's spotify wrapped
yes we actually have a story about it so
we will get into it the number one
listen to artists
globally of the year on spotify don't
guess okay i will share it with you okay
and we'll just share our year in music
okay so without further a
do it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
skylight frames the perfect thing for
someone in your life who you know you
don't get to see enough who you have
lots of memories with and you just want
them to know that you're thinking of
them that they are special to you the
skylight frame is a photo frame where
you can update instantly
by email from anywhere so it's a great
it's a digital photo frame it's a great
way to feel close to those you love even
when you're separated it's super easy to
set up in under 60 seconds just plug it
in use the touch screen to connect to
the wi-fi and enjoy sending photos from
your phone to the skylight is totally
effortless everyone in the family can
just email them to the personal skylight
email address and they pop up in a few
seconds it has a black and white
a black frame and white matte so it
looks like a real photo frame and it
just adds a beautiful touch to your home
perfect stocking stuffer perfect for
your mom or your grandma your grandpa
who live far away
and you you handle it all it's like even
if they're not super tech friendly it's
so easy and yeah you could
work on it from like miles away no it's
a great gift just for someone to just
have but then you also could be changing
the photos in there from a distance and
then that's something exciting to
connect you guys you could even like put
a little message in there yeah i
actually got one for ben's parents like
a while ago and they're obsessed with it
and like when we're on vacation i like
take a cute picture ben i like put it on
the
frame and they like love it it's like a
game it is it's very cool um and we have
a great offer you can get ten dollars
off your purchase of a skylight frame
when you go to skylightframe.com and
enter code toast so again that's ten
dollars off your purchase of a skylight
frame when you go to skylightframe.com
with code toast s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t
promo code toast
check it out okay our first story kim
and kanye put aside their drama for
virgil ablo's tribute in miami kim and
kanye put on a united front to appear
together at late designer virgo ablo's
final show for louis vuitton in miami
the divorcing couple along with their
daughter north paid tribute to the
label's former artistic director at his
spring summer 2022 collection in miami
on tuesday marking his final
presentation for the brand kim and kanye
sat front row at the final collection
billed as a celebration to the
designer's life and legacy at miami's
marine stadium with their eight-year-old
daughter north
so i think a lot of people were like
quaking that they were together first of
all like they have four kids together
and north was there like what because
their divorce kanye shouldn't say had a
kim in north like it's so stupid like
yeah i didn't think it was like a big
deal but i did think that this event was
beautiful like the things i was like the
drone lights and that big statue of
virgil it was really spectacular yeah
and the hot air balloon
nothing about this surprises me i do
think people are quaking like are they
getting back together i don't think this
means anything other than they both
loved virgil so much he was such a big
part of their lives and they're going to
be together as they mourn and celebrate
his life and like their kids are there
like
their family always and whether they do
get back together or they don't has
nothing to do with last night yeah it's
totally separate yeah but this does come
off the heels of like a very bizarre
instagram story from kanye like a week
ago with a picture of kim like a tmz
article just being like i'm getting my
family back and like tagging kim that he
was gonna like get kim back and inspire
millions that's what he said right that
would be very inspirational yeah and i i
really think that
they might get back together in like a
year but she needs to do her thing right
now because she stayed home for so long
stayed quiet for so long while he got to
run around right and now it's kim's time
and then i do but i do think they'll
find their way back to each other
especially if kanye never gives up right
you know because
it could be you know
convincing yeah no i could see that
being the end of this all like kim gets
to have her fun kanye is working on
himself being the best husband the best
father and then after she's had her fun
it's time to come home yeah so i don't
think that this was that last night at
all but she's not done she's not done
she's still having fun pete dudeson is
still you know taking her out to
breakfast at the beverly hills hotel
so
she's going to continue to ride this
ride um but this event was like really
sickening yeah i mean i wish i could
have been there but i saw obviously like
a million videos on social media and it
was really really gorgeous like a
beautiful way to honor someone and also
just like a very well done event yeah
did you see any of pieces from the
collection no i only saw like these art
installations like stuff in the sky yeah
like drones and hot air balloons hot air
balloon and there was a big statue of
virgil that was like an lv pattern very
cool but no i didn't see any actual
products yeah i'm looking forward to
seeing the 2022 spring summer collection
joggers
by the way i mean i don't know anything
like about fashion but like who takes
over for virgil now i'm sure that lvmh
has a successor in play in mind i wonder
who it is
hopefully someone talented that would be
ideal yeah you never know it's big shoes
to fill oh by the way whoever comes in
next like is screwed yeah but hopefully
there's someone talented and they can
take it in a new direction not just
trying to like recreate because you're
never going to be virgil no
no no
oh no
oh no no no no no
okay next story big news for bachelor
fans the new bachelor for season 26 has
been announced this is the first time in
my life where i don't even recognize the
person or the name clayton echard
etchard has been officially named as the
bachelor he is michelle's ex from her
current season is he on right now is the
show over
i don't think the show's over no so i
guess we know he doesn't win i guess so
or she already sent him home no that it
would be so early like that would be
like someone
so random getting i feel like he makes
it to the top four or something and like
we just know now that he's not it but
he's not like top two and also photos of
him filming with a camera crew were
leaked so maybe they wanted to get out
in front of it but that happens all the
time because they do say that they do
those packages with multiple people
kayla quinn was spotted in her hometown
right before they decide who it's going
to be so i do feel like they could have
kept it under wraps but this guy seems
really really cute did you see his
picture no he's a cutie the dogs he
looks like jesse palmer he does when i
saw
the headline and the picture i thought
that maybe it was like a random like i
didn't even know he was on the season i
was like maybe they just chose some
random hunk yeah are you gonna watch no
but like i'm
he looks real like this looks exciting
he looks like all-american he looks like
colton he looks like you know a
millionaire he does look like jesse
palmer yeah actually really similar to
jesse palmer and there's dogs in the
promo pic and then the slogan is
everyone loves an underdog which makes
me feel like his whole storyline is
about dogs which is like sweet to a
point or his whole storyline is like
about being a loser an underdog no no i
think he definitely probably like works
at an animal shelter
for sure
there's definitely like multiple dog
references in his life yeah i agree like
this is the first time i saw a poster
and i was like what show is this like i
know i didn't even recognize remotely
someone from like instagram yes agreed
or even the name of people that are
people are talking about like michelle
and blane no totally like i have
literally i'm sorry to this man
i don't do not know you no but it was a
kind of a cool feeling it made me feel
like like fresh like yeah it's a new
really a new season for the bachelor and
if you're a bachelor fans i hope this
guy is someone worth rooting for yeah i
it's so crazy i literally don't know
maybe it's just because i'm getting old
i do not know one person in my like
close media circle besides the snatcher
who watches the bachelor or who who
enjoys it yeah well your circle's pretty
small that's true
it's literally right
it's really a square it is a square yeah
uh so congratulations to the bachelor
fans who wanted clayton to be the next
bachelor you got what you wanted good
because it's the one you got clayton is
such like a bachelor name totally you
know everything about this is just like
classic bachelor like look at this so
he's going to be the first season hosted
by jesse palmer correct yeah that's him
or that's jesse parker that's him how
are we going to tell them apart you guys
this man actually really looks like
jesse palmer how are we going to tell
them apart so it's the first one that
jessie palmer is hosting right i guess
that will be hunk on hunk crime no it's
going to be like that spider-man meme
you you that's what the bachelor always
is though no but this is i've actually
never seen two people look so similar on
the franchise actually the fergie twins
those were the two people who looked the
most similar in my opinion yeah but i
don't know not everyone sees it
no i think people could see this yes
this is jesse palmer maybe it's jesse
palmer's like twin brother he's a former
tight end for the seattle seahawks
the bachelor is slowly becoming just
like a
destination for failed athletes yeah and
that works though i think that's great
yeah in great shape
hopefully they've got some money saved
up from their time in the league they
are used to a little bit of limelight
perhaps right they're not like thirsty
because they've kind of tasted it yeah
they're always you know waiting their
turn who else obviously colton is a
former uh
clay
clay i would say colton though is the
most
famous because he was the lead
because he was the character before he
was the bachelor like the most famous as
a football player like i had heard of
colton
i hadn't heard of him no but like jordan
rogers did he ever play in the league no
he like got benched and then quickly but
he has a lot of claims to fame well
because of his brother yeah that is
still the craziest [ __ ] ever i know
um who else played in the league i just
feel like it's always
only football though like i don't see
any mlb players in there yeah maybe
minor league
maybe
yeah well good luck clayton slash jesse
we're on to you
and hopefully you find love you already
have
are you ready for our next story only if
it's an x-ray that's brought to you by
liquid iv the only product getting me
through this extremely difficult
challenging week
liquid iv is hydration in a packet and
you've just got to get into it cooler
weather makes it easier to miss signs of
dehydration like overheating or
perspiration which means it's even more
important to keep your body fully
properly hydrated during the cold
weather so one stick of liquid iv in 16
ounces of water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone so if you
have trouble drinking water i can relate
because it's just like the most
disgusting thing ever throw liquid iv in
there it comes in tons of flavors tastes
so good and keeps you hydrated i mostly
use it for hangovers and it's extremely
effective just jam-packed with good
stuff um it's just if you're traveling a
lot going to see family you get really
dehydrated on planes just normally would
i be with you in your purse it's always
good to have whether you're drinking
alcohol or you're not just always good
it makes you feel good um
also they have a great charitable aspect
to their business they're on a mission
to change the world they've donated 4
million servings in response to covid
their products are being donated to
hospitals first responders food banks
veterans and active military grab your
favorite liquid iv flavors nationwide at
walmart or you can get 25 off when you
go to liquidive.com and use the code
toast at checkout that's 25 off anything
on the entire website when you get
better hydration using promo code toast
at liquidive.com
wonderful okay our next story spotify
wrapped and the most played artist on
spotify i think worldwide there's we
have a lot of dts
no but that's close there on the list is
it a man woman single female like
single male
hmm
oh like j balvin
no
bed bunny bad bunny wow that only took
three guesses that's awesome that is
pretty good for the second year in a row
wow with 9.1 billion streams it must be
so rich then number two was taylor swift
wow yes queen yes exactly and then bts
drake and then justin bieber and that's
for worldwide
hmm
okay is there an american one no there
is america okay because i'm thinking
that i saw on instagram today morgan
wallin posted something that he had the
biggest album three million albums sold
so wouldn't that put him and it was more
than olivia rodrigo and drake's album so
yeah
here's the us and but this is just for
spotify so if he's was selling album oh
that's true then
he's here but not in the way that you
would think so
here are the us
us most streamed artists okay number one
drake wow number two taylor swift queen
number three juice world oh number four
kanye west wow number five bad bunny
wow surprising kanye i mean his album
was huge yeah but it was like here and
then gone you know yeah then us most
stream songs the most streamed song
number one can i guess yeah
driver's license yes
let me keep getting going number two
easy on me no is it on that list no it's
not it came out too recently you can't
you can't compete with 12 months of
streaming no i completely agree okay
keep going number two is good for you by
olivia rodrigo right number three kiss
me more by doji cat wow
joshua is like
i know she's really famous but i feel
like she's really underrated
no i don't think she's underrated but it
is surprising that she's not on more of
these lists of like most played artists
because like every single one of her
songs is like number one on you know
everything spotify tick tock instagram
reels like everything instagram stories
everyone's putting it in their [ __ ] and
you know what's so weird like i've never
actively listened to doji cat but if i
went to a concert i would know every
song a hundred percent and that's called
impact yeah a hundred percent then heat
waves by glass animals i feel like
that's one of those like vibey tik tok
shows listen to it really quickly i feel
like it's because i've never even heard
of that no but i feel like it's going to
be something that you would know every
week glass animals
okay i'm watching
why don't you just go to spotify
can make that's the thing with tick-tock
like you know every song that you've
never heard of yeah no eat so even i
feel that way and i'm not on tick-tock
and i know that's well you watch the
regurgitated trash on instagram reels no
but also then those songs are the ones
that people choose for their instagram
stories soundtracks stuff like that
and then they like get put in
commercials and [ __ ] like because like
companies are trying to be cool yes and
then the number fifth the number five
song was levitating
that song was really big even though it
there's like so much drama around it why
because the baby is on it yeah
yeah like i think she like when she
submitted it to the grammys she
submitted the version without him
i don't think anyone really wants to
[ __ ] with him anymore yeah then the most
streamed albums number three this is so
random but i know we spoke about the
chappelle special i think the most
surprising part of the
chappelle special was that thing he said
about the baby did you know that
the shooting yeah no i didn't know that
i didn't know that either yeah just side
note i don't think we ever talked about
that u.s most streamed albums number one
let me think
sour yes
i'm so good at this number two
folklore oh that wasn't this year
dangerous oh yeah
was folklore this year no 2020 okay
number three
planet her by dojicat there she is there
she is number four justice by justin
bieber
and number five legend legends never die
by juice world so okay i have a lot of
things to say first of all the snatcher
have you heard about her conspiracy
theory by justin bieber you know what i
was just gonna bring that up because
it's feeling very pertinent to this
particular situation so
margot her one of her top five songs on
spotify this year was anyone by justin
bieber which is a gorgeous song gorgeous
but she was like that is just not in my
top five i did not listen to it that
much and so she put that on her story
and apparently a lot of other people are
reaching out saying the same thing
happened to me like it was not my top
five song of the year but it's coming up
in my spotify rapt and it's making
people feel like this shit's rigged okay
here's the thing i want to say one thing
i really don't think spot spotify would
sacrifice their data for justin bieber
like
i just think like there really is so
much honesty in the spotify rapt like i
just wanted
i i really believe it's strictly based
on data but
i do think justin bieber is showing up
in a lot of people's things because
maybe on spotify he's like a really
recommended artist they put all of his
songs in all these different playlists
and maybe that makes him show up more
not necessarily making it inaccurate but
just making it like kind of
like staged almost like of course he'll
be in everything but of course he'll be
in everyone's top we put him in every
playlist this year right he came up on
my top songs like in my overall playlist
so you know how they make you that 2021
playlist oh yeah which is so fabulous
yeah oh i wish there was numbers next to
it but he's probably like number
15 for me with anyone i don't think that
i literally have um oh my god stop stop
but i did have that song hearted so i
did listen to a lot very much so on a
plane with a tear in my eye i don't
think that i got any justin bieber on my
my top
spotify wrapped i got a lot of country a
lot of john mayer
together again by janet jackson like is
the song i listened to 45 times this
year um
45 actually oh no no no they do tell you
for some songs how many times yeah but
i'm just looking to see if i have any
justin bieber on mine and so far i don't
it's literally just
taylor swift rascal flats
honestly mine is all morgan wallin
dangerous the album i listened to it so
many times and i even took months long
break from listening to it and it still
dominated my spotify rapped so you know
what's so funny i think probably every
year since spotify has come out with
rapt a couple songs from the native
album by one republic always end up on
my top playlist because that to this day
is like in my opinion the most
critically acclaimed album of our
generation yeah i mean it's always a
good go-to album to listen to that's
something you should have downloaded on
your phone like buy the album when
you're on a plane it's so inspirational
yeah also
my top artists were so interesting this
year only because in number five a new
artist usually it's it's always the same
for me you know like little mix and
taylor and yeah yeah it's lady a but
mitchell 10 pen ain't made it's my top
five this is yes mitchell get it you
love to see it oh i love that for you
i love that song bucket list i was
listening to it this morning i was like
i think i listened to this song so many
times that he that he rose to my top
five artists mitchell 10 penny is out
here putting out some of the best music
in country music right now really true
and i'm really happy for him and
schnitzel as well and i'm really happy
for myself that we now have these
playlists of all the songs that we liked
most this year and now we get to listen
to it for all of december and you know
that your december streams do not count
towards any spotify wrapped not for you
not for this year so you could like
that's why holiday music never makes it
on you know what's really funny i'm
looking at my top artist
two out of five of my
artists
don't like exist anymore
one direction for this year yeah for
this year and rascal flats like it's so
funny i don't listen to new music like i
just love what i love like taylor swift
john mayer i love what i love and that
means sometimes listening to retired
music what i do is like i when i find a
song that i like i heart it and then i
only ever listen to my hearted songs so
it's the same songs over and over again
so usually my
top songs of 2021
is just my liked playlist yes but like
based on how many new songs i added like
things just get moved around but it and
also one of my big songs this year was
quite miss home by james arthur my
spotify wrapped is like a little bit
it's very kind of like a melancholy vibe
gold rush taylor swift because you were
in like coveted mode you're in pregnancy
mode you're not putting on like rain on
me
yeah no there's no bops like that
not at all actually when you go down a
little further when i was in my like
intense working out phase you you get
those songs dark times all i know no no
those were good times i have good
associations i was like running and i
was like yes little mix heartbreak
anthem give it to me david seriously
like probably the best song i've ever
made yeah
into it on repeat on the treadmill no
that song like does make me want to go
for a jog which is very rare see the
power of music they should release a 30
minute song for like someone who wants
to go for a jog yeah
how's belly belly's feeling good it's
nice and big and plump is that a
maternity shirt
it's another
maternity tee from the gap
the gap it's honestly so comfortable and
it really does make a difference to
where a material shirt yeah i don't know
what like the difference is i feel like
there's more width on the sides
but if i just like put on one of my
t-shirts that looks like this like it
would be deeply uncomfortable whereas
this is just i'm i have room to breathe
that's so fabulous yeah are you ready
for our next story some more music news
sure adele announces las vegas residency
beginning in january still no buckingham
palace adele has announced an exclusive
residency in the coliseum of las vegas
caesar palace hotel beginning friday
january 21st it will be titled weekends
with adele and the singer will perform
two shows each weekend through saturday
april 16th so it's not like a full like
lifetime residency it's like a special
yeah but it's not as like bogus as some
of the other residencies we've seen
where it's literally three nights in
vegas yeah i think that vegas really
took the word residency and ran with it
because residency means you have a
residence there like you live there
britney's residency was a residency
celine's residency was a residency
donnie and marie they live in vegas
that's a residency katy perry performing
two weekends ain't a residency cardi b
doing one show not a residency the we've
talked about this like the
terminology has changed and also this
way they're able to get like more
current performers who don't have
10 albums worth of stuff to play every
single night but you know it's more
relevant so this honestly is a really
good idea she'll probably like live in
l.a and then fly out on the weekends to
vegas she does live in ellen out full
time and that sounds like a nice way to
live your life and make some cash and
make some big money so she'll have a
total of 12 dates and if you're going to
any one of them
i'm happy for you i definitely um have
started you know talking to some peeps
about going one of the dates from
january to april
you're that's your busiest time yeah and
it's your busiest time as well i don't
see you making it there i wanted to ask
you something without triggering you but
i think i know the answer like you're
not coming to stagecoach right like
you'll have a two-month-old baby
it's uh um tbd like that's a totally
night
i might go or it might not go i might go
i see how i feel okay we always are last
minute about that stuff anyway no
totally i've been like just like
gathering tickets and yeah right
together
so i need not make any decisions i have
no idea what kind of like you're saying
i should like maybe save one ticket for
you
yeah i
i probably won't wind up going but i'm
not gonna make that decision right now i
don't know what kind of postpartum girly
i'm gonna be no i think you're
definitely gonna be a stagecoach
postpartum girl i mean i would love to
be that and also because luke is
performing and that would like make up
for everything that i've lost no i mean
i would literally uh like cut the
umbilical cord and run to stagecoach
like that would be me yeah so take the
kid home it's easy to say that you know
obviously
i think it i'm sure there are like moms
listening who are like laughing in my
face i'm not gonna go but i even think
that i might 100 percent two months
later you're gonna be like attached to
the kid i know you're not coming but
i'll still save you a ticket yeah
we'll talk about it but i'm not going to
decide right now and just write
something else off for myself you know
that's true you must be open to all
possibilities in this life exactly
are you ready for our fifth and final
story if it's a final story that's
brought to you by organifi a line of
superfood blends that offer plant-based
nutrition made with high quality
ingredients each organifi blend is
science-backed
to craft the most effective doses of
ingredients that are organic and free of
fillers and contain less than three
grams of sugar per serving like the
organifi green juice with essential
superfoods and a clinical dose of
ashwagandha okay apparently everyone's
been like on ashwagandha and i didn't
know about it until i started drinking
those organifi juices which are hella
good ashwagandha just really is like one
of those miracle superfood
items that makes you feel like clear and
lucid and it's just a fabulous product
and it tastes really good in the
organifi
and they also have
the effects of reducing stress
supporting healthy cortisol levels and
the organifi gold a superfood tea that
supports rest and relaxation so you can
wake up feeling refreshed so each
organifi blend is easy to use by you
mixing it with water or your favorite
beverage while you're on the go they
don't compromise quality for taste it's
true they really taste very good
organifi takes pride in offering the
best tasting superfood products on the
market so it works out to just less than
three dollars a day you can experience
organifi's high quality superfoods
without breaking the bank if you go to
organifi.com
toast and use the code toast for 20 off
your order that's o-r-g-a-n-i-f-i
dot com backslash toast and code toast
for 20 off any item i think you guys
will enjoy that
yes and our fifth and final story is a
bit of an update
sorry oh my god it almost slipped my
mind
it's the final story
justin bieber manipulated the spotify
rapt don't tell scooter brawn
well he would know if they did it he was
i really don't think that they did no
that is really funny that snatchers onto
this and it's just an interesting thing
she's just embarrassed that she listens
to that song so many times especially
because i wouldn't be it's really good
it's really good but um it's extremely
depressing
it's dark it is like it's but that's
fine and also like she's a little justin
bieber girly like it's fine snatcher
just admit it embrace it you've got the
bieber fever
she's sick with bieber fever it's not
covered it's the bieber fever
our vitamin final story is an update
from a story earlier this week lovely
bones author alice sebald has apologized
to the man who was wrongly convicted of
raping her she wrote a public statement
posted to medium where she issued an
apology to the man who was cleared last
monday of all charges in his 1982
conviction which served as the subject
in her best-selling memoir lucky also
netflix has scrapped the adaptation of i
think that's best of the best-selling
memoir after the news
and the book has been pulled by the
publisher in light of the exoneration oh
yeah
i mean
okay thanks to the apology but
i don't know like 16 years in prison i
just don't think an apology is going to
cut it yeah i mean but
she had to say something no of course
but
this is just not looking good what's her
name alice alice yeah
it's just a really awful story yeah and
i tried to do a little more research on
like her involvement in
the
conviction and it ain't looking good for
alice yeah like she was like you know
not completely clear yeah but she went
on to write that she was a traumatized
18 year old rape victim and she chose to
put her faith in the american legal
system okay i mean that is true she now
regrets but still like
at what cost you know a man's like 16
years of his life yeah this is just one
of those terrible stories where like
everyone's a loser yeah
agreed that's so sad but actually crazy
that they're pulling her book i mean it
literally tells the story
of like this like the worst thing in
this man's life something he can't do
right
and now it's inaccurate right and you
know i'm glad they're not moving forward
with like a series yeah there's just too
much yeah i know what the book has been
around for a while i'm surprised it
wasn't already made into something she's
been a really popular writer like since
we were kids yeah so i'm surprised it
wasn't made already and it's better that
it's not out there you know we just need
to let this
story just die down yeah
um well those were the past five i feel
as though you needed to know them for
sure and now a little tv recap shall we
yes i didn't have time to watch
vanderpump rules and i want you to tell
me what happened but we can also talk
about how
i believe tonight is the real housewives
of orange county like comeback episode
heather dubrow they're putting all
they're putting their entire foot into
heather dubrow
and i'm the thing about heather dubrow
though which and i love her i know
girlies she's not the main character
she's always like such a great asset
like side dish to the main course she's
a mashed potato with like creamy garlic
butter yeah maybe a little truffle but
she's not the meat
though she might be the potatoes so to
put it all on heather and also she's not
going to get dirty get her hands dirty
and like ruin her life and her
reputation and her manicure so
i think it's a faulty plan but there are
still other two other housewives
and shannon badour who i do will have
faith in
yeah she she'll get her hands dirty and
nobody tries to like stay above it but
like we see right through shannon she
doesn't play the game very well no but i
do believe we will now finally see
heather dubrow's house well that's
exciting which you know for the last
week actually all of last week they were
playing old episodes of oc on bravo and
i was really enjoying it
and it was the episode where
terry takes her to like this plot of
land that's like amazing and tells her
that he bought it and they're gonna like
build this whole dream house and that
was like literally like 10 years ago
yeah um i know it's on youtube but i'm
waiting to like really see the house
yeah no i'm good on a youtube tour um
i was gonna say also the real housewives
of miami trailer dropped did you watch
it i saw a clip of somebody yelling at
larsa pippen that she's a wannabe kim
kardashian which must have cut so deep
knowing she is a wannabe one kim
kardashian and isn't even friends with
kim kardashian anymore yeah yeah the
second part definitely hurts most but it
looks really good yeah it does so it's a
peacock only thing
i have to catch up on real housewives
ultimate girls trip i have a bunch of
flights coming up so i will be fully
prepped and are you think you're gonna
finish finish
pump rolls
well last night like i had the bandwidth
so i watched it and it
i don't mind like if i don't have to pay
attention and i can be on my phone then
it was fine it's just really getting so
infuriating last night's episode was a
complete waste of life well jackie's
gonna recap the pump rules episode from
last night which is brought to you by
bowling branch this cyber week bowling
branch is offering their best deal of
the entire year and if last night's
sleep wasn't incredible mine was because
i have bowl and brown sheets their
sheets will make all the difference with
bowl and branch you get the best sleep
of your life with the highest quality
organic cotton sheets so jackie and i
both have the signature hem sheets it's
their best-selling product and it's
beloved for a ton of reasons like how
they get softer with every single wash
which is true i've had the same set of
sheets for a year i wash them once a
week and they get better and better and
better and they never lose that cooling
effect which is so important to me when
speaking of sheets because i'm a very
very warm sleeper sometimes i sleep with
a heating pad and i just need to be kept
cool and bowling branch does that for me
it comes in a wide range of colors and
sizes from twin up to california king
they're completely toxin free and fair
trade certified this cyber week gift
your loved ones the best sleep of their
life or treat yourself with bowling
branch their holiday packaging and
famously soft sheets blankets pillows
and more make a difference everyone will
feel get 25 off from november 23rd
through december 2nd so that ends
tomorrow cyber week so check it out
their best offer of the year at
bowlingbranch.com 25 off at b-o-l-l and
branch dot com exclusions may apply
okay so last night vanderpump rules i
mean we're back the crux of the issue is
like katie versus tom sandoval and tom
is so staunchly team katie so staunchly
team katie so staunchly over this
storyline in general and if no one
checks tom sandoval then the show is
just going to go off the rails and the
thing is i think the fans majority of
them like him so sustainable yeah i
think that like i'm in the minority and
that i need to go i think i'm gonna go
before tom sandoval gets held
accountable
i'm actually shocked to hear you say
that i don't think that that's the sense
people are not
people
don't like katie not i mean it depends
who you're talking like if you look at
twitter they don't like katie they don't
like lala everyone else is like i can't
relate to these people i can't really
know so it's like if someone needs to
like be checked it's me and i need to
check myself out the door uh yeah on the
show you need to check out of the hotel
but the thing is
morally like we are on the right side of
history i know we are no
especially as it relates to katie and
tom sandoval he's just so infuriating i
mean this episode was just a farce you
know what i can actually see how like an
audience member like might not love lala
she's not everyone's cup of tea but i
don't know how you watch katie versus
tom and you consciously can sleep at
night siding with tom i have no idea but
then brock i think took the cake this
episode
and just
really um
upsetting me
because he
drank a beer out of his shoe
during his confessional
oh
so he was talking about it and you put
the shoe back on afterwards yes of
course so he when he went over to like
the tom and ariana's house and they were
talking about like chugging beers or
whatever he's like you gotta do a boot
chug and he was like i'll show you some
time and then in his interview i'm sure
they asked like what's a boot chuck so
he takes his shoe off what kind of shoe
a loafer like a dress shoe uh-huh
pours his cup of beer into the shoe i'm
gonna puke
drink sit
and then put tissue back on and that's
what i had to watch last night what do
you think is worse the concept of
drinking like sweaty foot beer or then
putting your foot back into a soggy beer
shoe the concept of drinking sweaty foot
beer but the second is still really bad
yeah no but like at least that's your
foot suffering versus your insides yeah
and you know he's got a sweaty shoe i
mean have you seen those thighs yeah
those shoes are working hard hard to
support those load-bearing legs right so
it was just something that's twisted it
was something i did not need to see and
i unfortunately i did see it and i don't
know how i'm sorry where i go from here
i'm really sorry then there was also
like this mad max pool party and i'm
sorry but like these themes are just
getting stupider and stupid
party like where we can just be normal
like and it doesn't have to be you know
like burning man in your backyard in the
valley no that's like a thing on summer
house in winter house too it's like
every party has to have a theme and they
look at so many boxes from amazon with
like luau signs and it's really stupid
well it's because they can't really go
anywhere i know but like in summerhouse
winter house it's like okay if you're
all staying in a house that's how we can
like differentiate every night that's
fine but like they're in l.a they're all
coming over to your house or we're going
somewhere like let us dress like
how we want to dress and sheena actually
was saying like she's so sick of these
theme parties because she doesn't have
anything to wear because like nothing
fits her right now 100 which i just so
related to
um but she looks everyone you know shows
up mad max style but it's just like what
are we doing no i know
uh it was it was really hard even if you
go continue watching you don't need to
watch last night's episode that that's
like some of the best thing you could
ever tell me story lines were just like
so thin lala sheena and katie went to
pilates and then katie and lala start
talking about tom sandoval because tom
sandoval and katie had just recently
gotten to a fight like a bad one where
he really disrespected her and they're
just talking mad [ __ ] and you know while
i can't stand him either and she knows
his name sheena's just sitting there and
then she then everyone else gets
together without katie and lala and she
says i felt so uncomfortable the other
day
the snitch of all time and so of course
katie and lala are like what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] it gets back to them and
she they were like i feel katie was like
i feel like you did that not because you
felt uncomfortable that we were talking
about him but because you didn't want to
like be seen as a bad guy who's like a
[ __ ] talker so if you snitch on us then
you're a hero right not like instead
they literally called her out flat on
her face
and she was like yeah no i'm sorry and
oh they ended like by hugging and i was
like but that's when you love sheena
like that's true she's messy but she
owns it she does like she really you
could see like the realization dawn on
her like oh i [ __ ] up yeah that wasn't
cool if i want these girls to be my
friends like that's not how a friend
acts no and like and if i really didn't
want you guys talking [ __ ] about tom
sandoval all i had to say was he's my
friend please comment yeah like you know
it was that simple yeah
so it was just so silly so silly i i'm
like afraid to ask like what's up with
the nose drum
nothing new but james is on so he's
sober from alcohol but apparently he
smokes weed every day every day and he
met up with his dad's friend who was
like
you need to you know quit weed so that's
his next step and he also wants to quit
nicotine too
um
and i i really hope that he has success
with it a lot i feel like a lot of
people they call it like california
sober demi lovato yeah so
i
but like he's like i wake and bake and
you know it it must be really that will
be a hard one yeah like if you rely on
it so much yeah that's tough so i hope
that he has success with that and that's
always rooting for james that might also
explain some of the other erratic
behavior that was like he said he was
taking like workout pills or something
yeah but it's like if you're
if you're still relying on substances
like then
there's still a problem there's still a
problem so we shall see well that sounds
exciting not enough lala ever we did get
a little baby ocean which was cute but
not enough lava for me there's never
enough lala for you no
all right well thank you for the
vanderpump rules recap but something
that we didn't talk about that happened
this week um lala selling merch of brand
new of her tattoo
which like to me is the nail in the
coffin we are never ever getting back
together no and like let's keep in mind
like lala's a single mom now and she has
bills and she was comfortable for a
while and now she's back on the hustle
and i very much respect that i do and
maybe i should just purchase a shirt to
support it
yeah because you should i mean you're
brand new
right
i'm so
brand new for sure so i know but i mean
as a and she renamed the podcast it
wasn't it was like lala and rand and now
it's just like give them all or whatever
it was give them lala with randall and
that was always like the second half
could always be take it or leave it so i
feel like she did that intentionally and
even watching the season it's like she's
so
everyone i'm sure will be like it's
foreshadowing what's going to happen but
she was like if
tom
tom schwartz like disrespected me the
way that like he disrespects his wife
you mean tom sandoval no schwartz he
doesn't have katie's back ever she was
like rand doesn't get to sleep next to
all of this like and it's really she
really did she talks she walks off the
wall she walked the walk and they feel
like at three and everyone's gonna try
and like come for her but it's like
she's doing everything that she said she
would if it happened to her right so
what else could you want no that's
actually a really good point yeah
um okay well thank you for that jax
thank you guys for the show just
reminder first little scheduling update
tomorrow's episode will be podcast only
and then there's no show friday but
there will be a brand new patreon
episode featuring the one and only
mames mamersons so
again thursday tomorrow's episode
podcast only friday patreon episode with
mamersince and jackie
correct yep that's it
thank you guys we'll see you back in
studio on monday if you're coming to see
my show this weekend i cannot wait to
see you guys minneapolis sold out
detroit still tickets available girls no
job.com tour and toronto i believe is
also sold out so i can't wait to see you
guys i love you thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cast box all the places swept
you'll see a podcast find us morning
trust and leave a five-star review about
how beautiful
stunning and smart we are have an
amazing day you guys will see you
tomorrow bye